hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute mache ich wieder ein
leckeres rezept von meiner mama und zwar
gibt es eine leckere suppe auf türkisch
heißt sie es in gent torgasse auf
deutsch super aus al-sintan also dass es
ist so eine region in der türkei oder
stadt besser gesagt da kommt meine mama
sogar her und es ist von meiner mama die
lieblingssuppe und zwar ist es eine also
das bändchen drin da sind selbst
gemachte nudeln mit drin
das ist eine tomatensuppe und aber auch
eine super mit joghurt also so ziemlich
viele verschiedene sachen kann man sich
vielleicht jetzt so nicht vorstellen
aber die schmeckt echt richtig lecker
man braucht ein paar zutaten und man hat
auch ein bisschen vorbereitung ich mache
jetzt auch meine nudeln selber ihr könnt
jetzt natürlich auch fertige nudeln
nehmen
aber ich finde der besondere geschmack
kommt eben erst durch diese selbst
gemachten nudeln mit dem selbstgemachten
teig und ich zeige ich es einfach kurz
im schnelldurchlauf die zutaten und zwar
brauche ich etwas sonnenblumenöl ich
brauchte tomatenmark hier habe ich jetzt
500 gramm park fleisch dass ich ein
brennender hackfleisch dann brauche ich
eigentlich eine große zwiebel aber ich
habe jetzt hier nur zwei kleine
charlotte noch gefunden in der
vorratskammer mit knoblauch später
wollen wir das dann habe ich hier für
den nudelteig zweier und etwa 200 gramm
mehl ihr braucht noch ein bisschen mehl
anschließend für die hackbällchen dann
einen joghurt dann nehme ich jetzt
wieder so einen festen joghurt mit zehn
prozent fettanteil schmeckt einfach
fällig ich habe hier ein paar gewürze
wie salz pfeffer
hier wo das paprikapulver ein scharfes
und hier habe ich noch minze und oregano
und chili natürlich und ich brauche dann
noch mittel wasser etwa zwei liter
und ich glaube ich habe hoffentlich
nichts vergessen herauszustellen wenn ja
dann sag ich s kleinsten zutaten wo ihr
daheim also eigentlich hat man immer
alles daheim vielleicht hackfleisch mit
wobei ich im tiefkühlfach im hackfleisch
ob muss ich euch dazu sagen
so und jetzt stelle ich erstmal den
nudelteig her obst und dann die anderen
sachen habe nachdem ich einfach mein
mail jetzt noch nicht komplett rein
sondern so etwa 150 gramm dann die zwei
eier hinterher etwas ganz natürliches
vorbild ev hat so eine krise und das
lassen wir jetzt erstmal verrühren
ich nehme jetzt erst diesen [ __ ] also
den flach hörer und später dann den
captain hook haken den nothafen warmer
jacke und eine öffnung gehört sich das
einfach mal verkneten und gebt dann
immer wieder mail dazu soll das ein
schöner fester nudelteig entsteht
es gibt ja auch nudeln teile die man nur
mit wasser macht aber ich finde der
schmeckt die jetzt gut mit weil das
einfach in das super dann besser kommt
also das finde ich halt länger
und wenn ihr merkt der teig wird zu
trocken dann einfach ein bisschen wasser
dazugeben
aber nicht zu viele soll weg dieser
festtag werden
und dann wechsele ich es einfach noch
den haken aus dem kneten herein und las
dann den nudelteig so etwa fünf minuten
völlig nähten
damit er nämlich richtig schön
geschmeidig und dann zeige ich euch
so sieht jetzt meinen nudelteig aus also
der schön festklebt aber auch nicht an
den händen und den muss ich jetzt
ausruhen lassen
ihr könnt den nudelteig übrigens auch
komplett mit der hand kneten als ihr
braucht keine küchenmaschine dafür
sondern könnt am anfang einfach so wie
sie mit der gabel die eier und das mehl
verrühren und dann einfach mit den
händen nach hilfen
so habe ich das früher auch gemacht als
ich keine küchenmaschine hatte ihr könnt
auch weil es ein kennwort das komplette
rezept in der kenwood machen also jetzt
vom nudelteig bis zur kompletten suppe
könnte alles in den topf machen oder
eben ohne küchenmaschine alles auf dem
normalen wert und ich mach das jetzt hat
auch normale hat damit ihr einfach sehen
wie das ohne herz gehen den nudelteig
lasse ich jetzt so etwa fünf minuten
abkühlen und in der zwischenzeit kann
ich schon mal das hackfleisch zu
bereiten
da nehmen jetzt einfach bisschen salz
und pfeffer und würzt es ein wenig und
ich lass das jetzt auch ganz kurz hier
drin verkneten da muss ich das jetzt mit
den händen machen das jetzt hier war
schluss gibt's einen halben teelöffel
salz dazu das war ich viel pfeffer und
lasst es ganz kurz durchführen sondern
können wir gleich die bällchen formen
der zwischenzeit habe ich übrigens schon
mal wer die fäden fein gewürfelt und
kann jetzt auch schon mal einen topf
leben einfach auf dem herzen
das habe ich hier den topf bereits
erhitzt und gebe etwa zwei bis drei
esslöffel sonnenblumenöl der 1
ich nehme jetzt auch absichtlich
sonnenblumenöl einfach damit es eben
geschmacksneutral ist da kommen die
zwiebelwürfel mit rein und werde jetzt
schön glas bedienstete beraten
es macht jetzt am besten bei mittlerer
stufe damit die eben jetzt nicht
verbrennen
jetzt gebe ich da noch drei esslöffel
tomatenmark dazu wenn das wir dann mit
gebraten also sind so 33 golf der ist es
wichtig nicht richtig gestört ist und
das werde jetzt mit gebraten dazu eine
minute und dann kann man es gleich
ablöschen
und jetzt lässt sich das mit dem
wasserball aber mir geht es neben free
thing police nicht darüber wenn man das
richtig kommt wird sich auto hat
ausgegangen
wieso kann ich mit käse mit ich hole mir
gleich noch das restliche wasser zu
machen kurz sauber und dann lassen wir
das ganz gut drauf
und es wird sich jetzt direkt mit zwei
treffern zum 2 1 1 können ist schon ein
bisschen mehr machen und am besten immer
frisch gemahlenem pfeffer
der schmeckt einfach viel besser als der
bereits fertig gemacht
da scheint noch viel mehr aroma mit
dringen salz nehmen wir jetzt mal so ein
teelöffel mag eine sache immer noch was
dazu geben dann auf jeden fall minze
dann nehme ich jetzt esslöffel fast und
oregano nimmer auf fast 1 esslöffel
destiny die zwei typischen gewürze von
meiner mama also die benutzten sie immer
und dann noch chili dann nehme ich jetzt
nicht zu viel weil ich will dass er mir
noch mit ist und dass ich jetzt hier
kurz aufkochen und kann in der
zwischenzeit hier drüben schon mal die
hak welchen formen
da können dann nämlich zurzeit einfach
ausnutzen das macht es mit handschuhen
weil ich jetzt das ganze fleisch dazu
anfassen wir sonst noch was geht
natürlich ohne und dafür nehme ich mir
einfach immer ein kleines stück und da
macht dass sie lieber etwas kleiner als
zu groß denn dann hat man dazu riesen
hackbällchen im mund und die werden
jetzt in diesem rechtlichen mail einfach
gewälzt
machen wir jetzt einfach irgendwas wird
also meine passion habe ich jetzt fertig
geformt und die gebe ich jetzt bereits
mit in dieses kochende wasser
das mache ich jetzt ganz vorsichtig als
so ein bisserl das meer abschöpfen
sieht aus wie ziegen die häschen bopanna
huub stevens immer runter gefallen
vorsichtig an der straße am rand teilen
lassen
also meine mama macht eigentlich nicht
so viel die bällchen rein aber ich mache
jetzt ganz viel suppe wenn man mal krank
und dann bringe ich ihr später auch über
das smartphone
und ich werde jetzt gleich wenn das dann
darin bisschen kocht aber werde ich die
nudeln ausrollen und die nudeln
schneiden
ich mache das natürlich jetzt mit der
nudelmaschine uns geht sehr schnell wenn
ihr jetzt keine nudelmaschine habt und
dessen im aufbaustab machen müsst dann
genießt das natürlich vorher machen
bevor er sich super an selbst weil sonst
kommt ihr zeitlich nämlich nicht hin und
könnt ihr auch die nudeln bisschen
antrocknen lassen es dann auch kein
problem
oder man nimmt einmal fertigen oder
anfertigen modeln das geht auch
selbstgemachtes inhalt leckere zu lassen
uns hier einfach noch einmal aufkochen
und ich nehme jetzt meine nudelmaschine
ich schalte das jetzt hier bisschen an
weil dann kann man es leichter ein
drehen und jetzt fangen wir mal an bei
der nächsten stufe der nudelteig dürfte
jetzt nicht kleben
daraus lasse und auch anfang falls es
denn immer mal wieder das merkt er
klebte zu bisschen also hat das bisschen
zu viel feuchtigkeit und dann einfach
wieder durch lassen
deshalb für nicht gegeben
einmal noch so gerollt mit der hand das
hatte ich auch noch oder einem austausch
zwischen mit alten italiener lud sie zum
will der italiener immer den nudeln ohne
aber das sind die türkischen oder mutter
ist japan oder dem internet das ist also
ehrlich da heißt es auf türkisch was wir
verpacken so und jetzt werde ich ein
bisschen jünger als ich aber ich will
jetzt auf den italiener im rauch weiter
genau und danone einfach mit wasser
mit linde zeit schneller das ist halt
der einfachere teil
ich mache das jetzt auch nicht ganz
günstig will dass diese bibliothek sind
bis stufe 7 und bis stufe 9 geht bei mir
also muss das ja so eine ungefähre
angabe habt
dass ich kurz liegen und macht es mit
der zweiten hälfte genauso jetzt kann
ich einfach den aufsatz wechseln
passau die maschine nicht ausmachen
dabei weil dann haben wir wieder
einfacher beim einsetzen was ich will
mal ich fertige nudeln kauf regen sowie
einkaufen als fetten modeln wird ich
entweder so bandnudeln nehmen oder so
ein model oder was auch ein rückpass zum
spätzle
also da freust du dich natürlich morath
man könnte jetzt auch ganz normale
fusilli oder andere nehmen aber damals
hat nämlich die tür ist gut wenn man
später in das alle türkisch aber das
metronom geht dazu schmecken würde würde
ich jetzt mal frage und jetzt habe ich
hier den tag leerer teller aufsatz und
kann das jetzt hier in dünne scheiben
oder in kleine lange lange bänder
schneiden
und es liegt mir das tier so hin weil
ich dir gleich noch zwei teile
jetzt nehme ich hier einfach so
eintreten oder ein scharfes messer und
kann die jetzt so in etwa ja so vier
zentimeter lange stücke schneiden
so dann wirst du das denn hat kleben und
die gebe ich jetzt einfach direkt mit
rein
jetzt dürfen die nudeln hier einfach so
ein bisschen kochen bis sie gar sind und
ich nutze die zeit um schon meinen
joghurt vorzubereiten
und zwar muss ich den vorhalt glatt
rühren damit es einfach keine klümpchen
gibt weil eben sehr fest der feste
joghurt ist und dann nehme ich jetzt so
ungefähr 500 gramm also das ist schon
eine große menge aber ihr könnt es
einfach auch nach eigenem belieben
machen also so wie es euch an steppt
könnte er ausprobieren mit weniger wird
desto mehr gleich da gebe ich jetzt die
knoblauchzehen mit rein
die reibe ich jetzt hier bin ich zum
beispiel jemanden hab da jetzt kein
knoblauch mal kann man natürlich
weglassen
ich wette zu machen weil wir halt auch
einen gast dabei haben
kein klub noch mal oder beziehungsweise
heute nicht erst milch werde ich jetzt
gleich ein bisschen suppe abschöpfen und
dann könnte einfach noch mal so ein
extra joghurt zu machen ohne knoblauch
mit salz und fertig und dann kann man
das eben so bringt getrennt machen
jetzt verriet dass man schneebesen
schön glatt rühren die suche könnte auch
inzwischen schon mal abschmecken ob wir
noch salz und pfeffer braucht oder
bisschen chili ich habe jetzt gesagt
wenn wir noch etwas salz habe ich auch
gleich noch mit dazu sind keine
klümpchen mehr drin
und das kann ich hier kurz stehen lassen
und muss jetzt noch in einem separaten
topf das mit der butter machen das ist
ja auch so typisch türkisch dafür nehme
ich einfach mit kleinen topf und geht
daten stück butter mit rein und zwar
sind es so etwa 20 gramm
und da gebe ich jetzt auch noch mal
gleich ich lasse erst verlassen und dann
gehen wir gleich die wird gewürzt mit
rein
jetzt gebe ich da ein bisschen von den
gewürze betreiben also vom scharfen
paprikapulver bisschen noch chili den
oregano und minze und dann darf das
einfach in der butter noch so ein
bisschen anbraten und es gibt daneben
noch mal ein leckeres schönes aroma aber
müssen aufpassen dass es nicht verbrennt
jetzt kann ich die suppe fertigstellen
jetzt gebe ich den joghurt mit dazu ganz
vorsichtig und dann immer schön
verrühren
weil wir denken jetzt bestimmt wie kann
man ein joghurt in die suppe geben aber
wird nicht das was sieht komisch aus
aber es lag ist auch so schmeckt aber
lecker wobei es bei unseren familien
nicht so gibt es gab sogar mama macht
simons trupps jetzt habe ich falsch
gemacht habe ich es falsch macht
eigentlich muss man erst ein bisschen
super zum joghurt gebe damit der yoga
oder bisschen warm wird und dann gibt
man ihn wieder zurück in den topf
eigentlich sieht es aus wenn die
schwäbische fleht lesen ja ein bisserl
anders
sie soll jetzt schön verrühren weil
jetzt habe ich nämlich dass opa joghurt
brücken drinnen ist natürlich nicht so
schön aber ich glaubte morath
verzeichnet ist
aber ich wollte das einfach gleich noch
klappt mit dem schneebesen und dann
durch das wieder weg ich bin heute hoch
konzentriert weil wenn man halt von der
mama rezept hat will man das hat auch so
machen wie thema marke also ich würde
sogar noch ein bisschen mehr yoko 3 und
gäbe aber ich glaube für demokratisch
das doch gut ich gebe mir dann einfach
diese joghurt in der teller so zum
servieren
es ist mir aufgefallen dass alle darüber
mama schmeckt aber ist von klein auf das
ist immer am besten schmeckt auch wenn
es andere nicht ist
technisch ist es meine mutter habe nicht
mal die hunde gegessen aber ich mag
gemein doch sogar die bundeshaus
rumgelaufen auf schwarz das muss man
einmal abspecken
aber ich fühle das leder einfach ich
weiß nicht warum hmm hält immer noch ein
bisserl salz also ich hab eine
riesenmenge hier mit zwei litern super
aber ich bin lieber ein bisschen
vorsichtig mit dem salz das erhöht das
noch kurze man kann dem rad bleibt
probieren
so jetzt gebt mir hier dies so verein
und dann kommt nämlich noch von dem mit
dazu das können wir jetzt entweder
komplett mit dem die suppe mit rein
geben also diese butter mischung oder
ihr geht es einfach so bisschen als deko
obertraun dass diese liegt diese quote
mit pausen typische speise fast überall
drauf
die aua herz machen können für dich
denkt er als wäre es nicht so aus wie
jetzt kann ich das einfach mal probieren
ich habe noch sehr hat ja ich wollte
mich ab gefühlt und dann war der natur
sondern ich mache ein bisschen zauber
jetzt ganz liebe zuschauer schaut euch
nur an die mainz aussieht und schaute
man an wie das aussieht was
fotografierte ja entschuldigung wenn du
drei erweiterung ich hoffe er hat ja
schon kopiert und sie ist immer wie toll
das ding aus sieht wirklich und das ding
wahnsinn alles probiert aber das ist auf
meinen teller da schon probiert und
teller verschwörung identisch und ich
hab doch schmeckt jetzt mal richtig
meint dass ich jetzt weiß nicht warum
ich sie geheiratet hat bezahlt sein kann
in solchen momenten merkt so etwas
richtig gemacht woran ich wurde
gezwungen
aber jetzt das ist ein anderes thema ist
jetzt auch gleich meine suppe dann haben
wir gleich unsere eigentliche fast schon
wie eine hauptspeise als ich finde diese
bestätigen
das ist einfach lecker ich könnte jetzt
auch der ganze topf glaube ich alleine
und die menge der klös hier sind auch um
liebe müssen ich würde mich giganten ja
und wenn ich das rezept gern nach machen
wollt dann geht einfach auf meinem blog
vorbei auch sallys - blog.de der monat
märz noch bissl ins mikrofon rhein ist
eure meinung nach dieses rezept wirklich
platz ja und mich sehen uns dann ganz
bald wieder mit einem anderen leckeren
rezepte und ist natürlich nicht alleine
meine mama grenzenlos bis dahin tschüss